[Música]
siguen atrayendo tanto a los niños como
a los adultos hablamos de las marionetas
durante todo el año Jackie y su hija
Caroline recorren las carreteras de
Francia con su espectáculo de griñón
esta semana los marionetistas
itinerantes se instalan en Twitter en
unos cuantos minutos preparan la sala y
montan El pequeño retablo hecho a mano
con la ayuda de mi padre
espectáculos Somos la quinta generación
en la familia se representa al guiñol
desde hace 70 años y donde quiera que
sea el público asiste
[Música]
uno
45 minutos de espectáculo gritos y risas
niños y adultos quedan conquistados
[Música]
todo el mundo no logra hacer esto
continuará a los niños y a los adultos
los abuelos las abuelas las madres tan
solo con marionetas
son mis niños Sin ellos no soy nada y
sin mí no son nada
[Aplausos]
guiñol La marioneta más ilustre fue
creada en Lyon en 1808 por un tal lo
Rangel
dos siglos más tarde El pequeño
personaje y su compadre nefrón No han
perdido nada de su insolencia
una cosa es cierto guiñol y nafrón
nacieron casi que al mismo tiempo con
una diferencia de uno o dos años y poco
a poco lo van empezó a hacer pequeñas
sátiras políticas sobre la sociedad de
la época
ella pisco se pusity la vida de Florence
es inseparable de la historia de La
marioneta en 1948 sus abuelos antúan e
ivon morrich fundaron el teatro guiñol
del parque de lag una institución que
hará morirse de la risa generaciones de
Pequeños leones
Yo estoy aquí desde que soy muy pequeña
vivía en la cruz con mis abuelos estaba
aquí todos los miércoles sábados
domingos vacaciones escolares feriados
llueva truene o relampaguee eh eh que se
fue Sin City Guay Ay Ay Ay Ay Ay Ay Ay
Ay Ay Ay Ay Ay Ay Uh La La La La La el
guiñol no ha pasado de moda aún así las
marionetas ofrecen un potencial de
creación ilimitado
Maguey hacen parte de una compañía de
teatro talabar hace 15 años que las dos
mujeres crean espectáculos de marionetas
un verdadero arte plástico
las piedras son de fabricación casera no
son de verdad De qué están hechas es el
mismo material con el que esculpimos las
cabezas es espíritu que después es
empapelado con papel periódico para que
quede más duro y luego se pinta cada una
aporta su saber hacer y su talento poco
a poco los elementos toman forma para
contar una historia salida de su
imaginación
yo pienso en la decoración el ambiente
personajes y sandrín se ocupa más del
tema de la historia y luego hablamos que
usamos nuestras ideas y así nace el
espectáculo
entre la escritura la puesta en escena
la creación de las marionetas y la
decoración son necesarios entre 9 y 12
meses para que las dos artistas puedan
concebir un espectáculo porque aquí todo
es casero hecho a mano
en este momento estamos investigando
para tratar de hacer brazos un poco más
largos en nuestras marionetas y
compensar este espacio vacío que tenemos
entre dos dedos donde paran tus falanges
aquí primeras falacas primeras falanges
no podemos hacer algo cónico
la expresión es difícil de encontrar
porque hay que encontrar una expresión
neutra una marioneta que ríe todo el
tiempo sonríe todo el tiempo no sabemos
Por qué en los momentos poco menos
divertidos ellas sonríe no debe dar la
impresión de estar muy triste tampoco
resultado de este trabajo minucioso un
espectáculo de marionetas Encantador y
lleno de emociones pero no inocente
Tratamos de sugerir una reflexión o
hacer surgir una emoción o compartir una
discusión luego entre padres e hijos
sobre un tema relacionado con el
convivir los temas generales de la
convivencia es decir la tolerancia el
compartir la ayuda etcétera
desde la creación de la compañía en 1987
y las artistas han creado 14
espectáculos distintos en especial han
encendido miles de estrellas en los ojos
de niños y adultos
[Música]